[Music]
from one Halloween movie with
under-wraps to another one with
Halloween town but sadly unlike under
rats this is pretty much exactly what I
thought I was gonna get with a cheap
lame Disney Channel movie
I guess they made a couple sequels to
this but God helped me if I can figure
out why this is stupid
this is the kind of movie you would see
a Mystery Science Theater it's filled
with hokey acting lame effects and
surprisingly not very creative ideas
that is to say the initial setup is not
that bad
three kids are forbidden to go out on
Halloween because the mother says they
can't but things start to turn around
when their grandmother played by the
late Debbie Reynolds literally flies in
and says that she needs the mother's
help the kids over here follow the
grandma and discover that she is in fact
a witch and they follow her on this
magic bus to Halloweentown and if you're
anything like me you're thinking
halloween town is gonna be something
like halloween town the one from
Nightmare Before Christmas weird
buildings dark creepy odd everything a
little askew but nope it's a bright
cheerful place that just has a bunch of
people and Halloween masks oh I mean uh
ghouls and goblins ooh but Halloween
town is in trouble because this evil bad
guy who kind of looks like a mix between
the Grim Reaper and Jim Carrey's Grinch
and acts about a subtle once Halloween
town to take over the land of the humans
so they don't have to live apart anymore
actually doesn't sound like that bad of
a plan I'm not sure why they're separate
anyway but nevertheless the grandma
tries to teach the kids how they can be
little witches and warlocks to come
together and stop his evil magic okay so
from a setup like this obviously story
is not gonna be a biggie this is some
excuse to have some really creative
images and ideas and characters and so
on and so forth and that's not for the
most part what we get here the writing's
not especially imaginative it just sort
of goes by the numbers Hey look a ghost
Hey look a werewolf
the acting isn't necessarily all full
but it's just bad enough like the 13
year old is supposed to be odd and
strange and a bit of a weirdo seen is
how Marnie likes weird
come on she's got the weird part down
pat Halloween is like made for her okay
look and listen to this kid and tell me
if you would get that and how are we
supposed to grow up if we can explore
the world try new stuff and take some
risks uh-huh No
Daria is a weird kid the Monster Squad
are weird kids you're like the
cheerleader from American Beauty trying
to be weird but doing a really bad job
at it because you're the everyday
average kid there's nothing odd about
you the brother is the typical geek with
all the analysis and book smarts theme
brings up at every single moment because
that's all he is
give me a good nature documentary any
day well that candy causes cavities and
gum disease
trees are important too you know
everyone's got their thermostats set to
68 degrees degrees science that's my
entire character never seen that before
and the smallest one is so bad they only
give her a sentence at a time he'll
sometimes just a word at a time
Ellie's pecan game I wish slack the
turncoat frog the bad thing the only one
who's ever doing a good job is Debbie
Reynolds I don't know what it is she
acted like every single part she got was
the role she always wanted to play she
just puts everything into it and she's
100% believable even in such a silly
idea languages they're mean and scary
oh no no no sweetheart I mean they're
just like everyone else and what kinds
I'm amazing that's thank yous they're
magic aside from that I'll give some
credit to some of the creativity in the
make up I mean don't get me wrong
they're obviously masks they don't look
real but they're kind of like the Evil
Dead movies you know they're fake but
they're very creatively fake some of
them have really cool designs and I
specially loved this skeleton taxi
driver Oh first time except you kids
look at this thing
look how expressive it is it would have
been so easy just to have a skeleton in
a cap hat and just have the mouth move
up and down but look at this the
eyebrows have allow motion the mouth is
moving left and right as well as up and
down it's actually a really good effect
but then they ruin it with this line fry
animatronic Daniel ants full of stuff
like that yeah dad don't ruin the
illusion that's like someone coming out
to the Muppet Show saying yeah you're
probably all puppets most likely from
the Jim hen
in studio little douchebag once in a
while there's a joke that gets a little
bit of a laugh like I enjoy how the
witches microwave has boil and bubble
and toil and so forth there's a fun
little segment where the kids have to
get ingredients for a spell like pair of
a werewolf Fang of a vampire and s'what
of a ghost how do they do that in this
world by going to a barbershop a dentist
and a gym of course leavings are
probably the film's best line ghosts are
dead why would they where you got
Fitness but aside from that it's pretty
empty I mean just look at this place
when I hear Halloween talent I want to
see something dark and creepy and
whimsical not just any other town with
people wearing some masks it's kind of
like a mix between a bad goosebumps
episode and that really lame babes in
toyland starring Keanu Reeves the few
creative elements are nice but it's not
enough to cover up the cheapness of both
the writing and the budget I suppose if
you have like little little kids this is
fine or I don't know maybe it did have
more of an audience I thought they made
a ton of sequels but when you hear
halloween town and you think of
something more like what the cover looks
like as opposed to this bright suburban
sunny day then i say this is a definite
pass
[Music]
you